[Music]
on the dish this morning colombia not
the country but the oldest restaurant in
florida and for regulars and national
treasure colombia is a blend of cuban
spanish sicilian even a bit of german
that's been going strong for more than a
hundred years through wars pandemics and
economic upheavals the same family has
expanded and evolved the restaurant now
in its fifth generation of leadership an
american success story
with global roots
[Music]
what is it about colombia that keeps
people coming back
what's the story of a family that
immigrated from cuba and from spain with
a dream
the dream began just after the turn of
the last century
cuban immigrant casimiro hernandez was
looking to fill the bellies of workers
going back and forth to cigar factories
in tampa bay's historic ebor city
during the great depression his son
built the first air-conditioned dining
room in tampa in the 50s and 60s when
ybor city was dying colombia kept it
alive
post-war the business expanded to
sarasota to the south and in the 1980s
saint augustine to the east
led by richard gonzmartz fourth
generation at columbia
and now his daughter andrea
fifth we actually live this next door to
one another i didn't know that yeah yeah
we don't get enough of each other at
work so we have to live next door should
come over at five in the morning we'll
start talking and we'll go on a walk and
at night time we'll go back and forth
andrea gunsmart started working at
columbia at age 10.
richard says he's been thinking about
running a restaurant since he was three
and a half
he still does from the moment he wakes
up not too long after the crack
of midnight
i love that that moment you know from 1
30 or 3 in the morning 1 30 1 30 in the
morning yeah it's a good time to wake up
and that's when you're looking at the
industry planning out i'm reading what's
happening in the world and the industry
and understanding to predict what's
going to take place
be prepared you never get tired of that
god that's what i live for
he eats sleeps and breathes
the restaurant business that's all i
know
richard now 68 refers to himself not as
president or ceo of columbia
but caretaker in the last year he's also
added a sicilian restaurant in ibor city
and now operates a total of 14
restaurants under six brands he's still
pushing and opening new restaurants he's
an animal
he claims he's trying to pass the baton
but he's running too fast for me do you
tell him to calm down or you just let
him let the let him go i ride the wave i
love it i'm always right behind him on
all of his crazy ideas there's a lot to
get done
[Music]
among colombia's staples a cuban
sandwich that they proudly proclaim
predates anything served in the nation's
most populous cuban locale miami the
most important part of beginning a cuban
sandwich is starting with great cuban
bread it is served to richards exacting
instructions
my father says it's important that you
go in this exact order
otherwise when it hits your palate
it's not going gonna taste the same so
we're gonna start with the ham okay and
each of these layers
symbolize
the people who came to ybor city in the
turn of the century so this represents
the spaniards that came obviously the
cuban bread represents the cuban yes
okay but our next layer is also going to
represent the cubans
it's the mohomerity roast pork there's a
ritual to it
i mean it's it's almost therapeutic yeah
we use only the salami and pour it from
italy that's got the peppercorns in it
and this represents the sicilians who
came to ybor city and now we're going on
to the swiss cheese which i always say
this almost represents ybor city because
it was truly the melting pot of all of
these different cultures coming together
so when you put it on the press or if
you don't put it on the press
it tops it all and marries them all
together it's hard to find a more
inclusive dish yeah right
[Laughter]
the columbia cuban is topped off with a
single thin layer of mustard a nod to
germany and always exactly two pickles
follow the simple recipe and you get
something exceptional
or you just mess it up from the start
did i do it oh shoot hello now you've
got an upside down cuban i do
[Laughter]
it's a special sort of cuban like my
it's an upside down cuban
[Laughter]
the cuban sandwich preparation was just
a prelude to the wider spread each one
of these dishes you could write a book
on
the history behind it
almost yes our table included colombia's
legendary
1905. a julienne style salad always
prepared tableside
pompano in papayote
seafood baked in a parchment crust
pollo manchego
crab croquettes
and in the middle of it all the completa
cubana the complete cuban it tells you a
taste of what i remember cuba the roast
pork marinated the mohum the bulichi
which is the iran with the cherries and
engraving the empanadas
fried plantains yucca which is a root
with a garlic and the black beans and
rice with the onions the black beans are
the way we did totally vegetarian the
paella and siana
our rice comes from mercia from the
south it's the way i would have had it
when i visit spain for desserts flan
along with an irresistible white
chocolate bread pudding
[Music]
just some of the food
and family that have kept people coming
back for more than 117
years
[Music]
these are some of the best
times
what do you think your dad would think
of how you've taken care of the
restaurant and what you've turned it
into my father had a lot of dreams i
have a picture of him when he was a
little boy he was a violinist
and he didn't get to do many things he
wanted to
i fulfilled every dream he ever had
and so i feel my dad would be very proud
wow he's an emotional guy and such a
successful guy and cares so much
about this restaurant never wants to
sell and one of the great things about
colombia beyond the food and the
atmosphere everything is you go and you
talk to the people who work there yeah
you ask them how long you worked here
for 30 years 20 years yes everything 30
years all family they just keep people
around because they treat them right
that's awesome yes they treat them like
family they like them that food looks so
good this and this
looks good
i'm sorry we couldn't bring all that up
from florida but we've been that's okay
with a custom-made pitcher here
gonna spill the garnish